and I give it my all I mean I practice
every day and I try and stay authentic
and uncompromising
I could probably rob banks or
burglarized jewelry stores and be very
clever about it hello elimination my
name is Evan Carmichael my one were to
believe I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the world's major
problems so today we honor two legendary
director actor named comedian Woody
Allen and my statement
toptenz rule number two is my personal
favorites and I'd love to know which
ones you guys like the web and as always
as you're watching if you something
that's pretty president with you please
leave it in the comments below
so folks around other people can be
inspired my kind of prize as well and
also with Reddit and which might be to
stick to yourself as well joy
[Music]
the business has changed that filmmaking
is the same I do the same thing now as I
didn't take the money and run I go in
the morning and instinctively actually
you you have a vision because you wrote
the script so you know what you want on
the screen and you execute to try and
get as close to that vision as possible
you never really come that close to it
but you die trying to get as close as
you can
the fun is in writing the film and then
testing it and getting the costumes and
working with you know talented people
and sophisticated gifted men and
charming beautiful women and coalporters
music and you know you work for a year
on something or six months on something
and it's great and it's fun then you're
solving solvable problems so if I can't
get my third act on a film right it
doesn't mean I die you know it just
means that the film won't be good and
maybe I can solve that problem and I
think about it and it's a fun way to
spend your life and then it's over if
you're thinking of rewards if you're
thinking of box office or that critics
after like it or that the public has to
like it you're dead you're depending on
things you're getting your ticks in the
wrong area your kicks have to be making
the film the actual joy of making the
film and the disappointments and how you
circumnavigate them and and solve the
problems and all that and then when so
will you look at it and you think oh God
when I wrote it it was so great and now
it's so terrible how did this happen
what went wrong did I did I made all the
wrong choices I you know and you and me
well the next one will be better and you
put it aside and you go on to the next
film but if you're there and you're
thinking well I can't wait till the
critics see this I can't wait till the
public breaks the doors down and
and the box office records you know then
you're dependent for your enjoyment on
other people's tastes and other people's
opinions and and I'm not interested in
their opinion I the first time I ever
worked on what's new pussycat was a load
singing film I hated the experience they
took I was doing the scriptwriter they
took my script and mangled it they put
the film out the film is big hit it made
the most money of any comedy to its time
at that time and I got no joy out of it
I was embarrassed by it I hated it so
you don't get joy from critical
successful public success you get joy
from realizing the work of art that you
were trying to make when you were laying
on your bed writing the script and then
also you visualize it and you made it
happen you spent you know 15 million
bucks or something
or more sometimes and made it happen
and and you say gee I'm proud of this
and I remember very clearly I walk the
streets I walked and I walked out I
didn't know what was going through my
mind it all seemed so violent and unreal
to me and I wandered for a long time on
the Upper West Side you know and most of
it powers you might my feet hurt my head
was was pounding and and I had to sit
down I went into a movie house I I
didn't know what was playing or anything
I just I just needed a moment to gather
my thoughts and be logical and put the
world back into rational perspective
and I went upstairs to the balcony when
I sat down and you know the movie was a
film that I'd seen many times in my life
since I was a kid and I always loved it
and you know I'm watching these people
up on the screen and I started getting
hooked on the film you know and I
started to feel how do you even think of
killing this self I mean even it's so
stupid I mean look at all the people up
there on a screen you know they're real
funny and and what if the worst is true
what if there's no God and you only go
around once and that's it well you know
don't you want to be part of the
experience you know what the hell it's
not all a drag and I'm thinking to
myself
geez I should stop ruining my life
searching for answers I'm never going to
get and just enjoy it while it lasts and
you know ask the who knows I mean you
know maybe there is something nobody
really knows I know maybe it's a very
slim read to hang your whole life on but
that's the best we have and then I
started to sit back and I actually began
to enjoy myself and I give it my all I
mean I I practice every day and I try
and stay authentic and uncompromising we
don't play any you know crowd-pleasing
stuff we don't you know get out there
and play when the saints go marching in
and you know will we play blues hymns
ragtime whorehouse music stuff that was
authentically New Orleans and we play it
in the New Orleans style as best we can
and so I don't feel that I'm a sellout
I'm doing the best I can the trick is
and it sounds facetious sometimes but
it's not you hire great people great
actors and actresses and then you get
out of their way you don't play the
director you don't hover over them you
let them change your lines you let them
make up their own contributions and do
things because the people that I've
worked with have had careers and a
famous and are great before
they met me and they're great in my
movies and they're great after they
leave me and so nothing special is
happening if you just hire wonderful
people that's all you have to do and
just don't mess them up
don't ruin them and you know it's really
a very simple thing then you get credit
for directing memories as well you did
such a great job so it's but it isn't
you're just not screwing them up that's
all successful for me in my terms are
when I'm home lying on my bed and I'm
writing something I have these
incredible ideas I think I'm going to
write Citizen Kane every time out of the
box and it's going to be great and then
I make the film and I'm so humiliated by
what I see afterward I think where did I
go wrong was it was it the editing was
that my writing that I was I lacks in
the directing so when I finally get a
film and I think hey this film is pretty
close to what I was writing at home I
think this is a successful film husbands
and wives was a film like that I thought
that I brought that but I had an idea
and I brought it off
I could probably rob banks or
burglarized jewelry stores and be very
clever about it you know I'm imaginative
I've got a sense of humor I've got an
original approach you know maybe like
you know this community to think if we
had I thought about it for a while and
talked about certain conman schemes with
my friends but by that time some of my
jokes were already being accepted by
radio and television and I saw the light
at the end of the tunnel and I thought
hey I could probably make a living being
a comic a writer of comic you know
material and I succeeded at that very
rapidly fortunately as soon as I started
doing it I started succeeding and I
started getting paid for it and so it
saved me from you know like I do think
in everybody's life there there are
times when there are turning points in
your life when I'm suddenly realize that
something momentous is can possibly
happen if you make a choice and if you
make the choice if you make the right
choice great in this case the choice
that Wilkie makes is irrational but it's
not so irrational
given the comparison with the choices
that we all make in our lives you know
if you if you look at you know people
people need something to hear bells
people need something to believe in in
their lives they have to choose whether
they you choose whether their life is
going to be meaningful for you or
meaningless then people will choose
religions and their lives for example
and they they'll make an irrational
choice they'll think that if they live a
very good life they will die and go to
heaven and live in heaven for the rest
of their life they they that's no less
crazy a thought then Joaquin thinking
that if he commits this act his life
will suddenly turn around for the better
did as long as there's something
dedicated that you can believe in you
make a choice in you and you go with it
at that point in my my life I was for
whatever ridiculous reason very taken
with the films of Chaplin and Keaton in
relation to myself and it's not
ridiculous that I'd be taken with the
film's they're great but but I I was
trying to to learn from them to see what
I could and I had the idea that they
were working
in the silent era and that was easier
most people think that silent films were
hard as silent comedies or harder
because you didn't have a voice you
couldn't speak but silent films were
easier when you added the voice it
became much more complicated and it's
really the difference between checkers
and chess
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much watching I made
the decision because Seguin the college
athlete so there's a famous on screw
that do you want me to profound fact
check out the link in the description if
you can go and cast your vote after let
us know which clip residence and most of
you what lesson you're going to teach
this video and immediately apply human
life or to business somehow leave it
down the comments below
I'm really curious that's what you have
to say I also want to give a quick shout
out to sign understand geez Simon's
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and make that
the music video on it as well I really
appreciate sport and I'm so glad that
you enjoyed and this video I'm doing a
video review of the one word by Evan
Carmichael thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you complete each
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love
[Music]
all the years you've been making movies
can you tell us what you've learned and
if you had a chance to remake any of
your movies or have you ever wanted to
read make any of your movies which ones
would you do well you learn stuff but
very little you learn stuff after the
first first two or three movies you
learned all you're really going to learn
most of the stuff can't be learned it's
instinctive so there are a few technical
things that you learn about editing and
adding music and you know little
technical things but you learn them very
quickly and the rest you either rise or
fail on the basis of your own talent or
your own instinct and it fails you
sometimes and sometimes it works for you
I would shoot them all over if I could
you know as Charlie Chaplin
had the luxury of shooting a whole film
all the time and he could look at it and
study it then shoot it again should
again if he wanted to films were not
that costly at that time they had it
definitely you know the actors the money
it was very simple I can't do that so
when I make a film I never ever look at
it again once I put it out because if
you look at it again you can always see
what you did wrong and how you can
improve it and why it's as terrible as
it is so I would shoot them all again I
could very happily take any movie I have
and improve it if I could get the cast
back and the circumstances exact roll
back time get the money I can improve
them all after seeing them start to
finish up there